[Musique]
j'ai ma présentation
je suis vraiment un beau cadeau je suis
étudiante avec chine en faculté des
sciences de santé de l'université abdou
moumouni de niamey mais où vous avez ça
je suis engagé dans plusieurs
associations qui oeuvrent pour le
développement du lard pour la santé
notamment je suis lavé les dents des
jeunes ambassadeurs pour la santé de la
reproduction et la planification
familiale au niger je suis un gamin
passionné par les oeuvres caritatives
notamment du mali c'est un jeune talent
humanitaire et je suis passionné par le
digital
je suis en train de développer
l'application intitulée kim à ski qui va
favoriser l'accès aux services de santé
pour les populations ni généraux alors
attends coutume de dire que les jeunes
sont l'avenir les jeunes sont le
lendemain des jeux sont le futur
c'est bien beau tout ça mais je suis
contre cet ancêtre assertion je suis
content l'ensemble de tes d'agression
pourquoi parce que pour moi est jeune
nous sommes le plaisant
nous ne voulons pas que l'on travaille
avec nous à l'avenir ou que nous
intervenons dans l'avenir nous voulons
agir maintenant parce que nous avons des
choses à rêve maintenant nous avons des
choses à changer maintenant nous avons
les capacités à mettre au service du
développement de notre vie maintenant ce
n'est ni demain ni après demain c'est
tout de suite et maintenant
vous savez je danse je vois des
interviews et le thé question qu'on me
pose quand je fais des indices us et
dites nous pourquoi vous vous êtes
engagés si tout est question que j'adore
je l'adoré quand je maintenant en fait
je donne je parle pas parce que j'ai
peur mais je tremble pas ce que j'ai à
te renvoyer la question à celui qui me
la posent et de juillet pourquoi est ce
que vous vous posez la question à savoir
pourquoi je suis engagé tôt posément
tout simplement la question de savoir
pourquoi je me suis engagé parce que mon
âge et finit par des capacités et les
capacités ne définissent pas mon âge
mais peut-être que cette pièce
mais si je vous disais aujourd'hui que
vos défauts sont plus puissants que tout
autre pouvoir de levy
vous allez pourquoi à ce que vos défauts
c'est ce que vous connaissez le mieux
souvent nos qualités on n'a même pas
conscience qu'on a les qualités on a
besoin que quelqu'un ne pousse pour
qu'on sache mon africanité
mais vos défauts que se fonde le
collègue ne les connais mieux que vous
ne et l'autre chose aussi c'est que vous
pouvez vous appuyer sur ses défauts la
en faire un socle en scène une base vous
développer des qualités
alors là vous vous dites qu'est ce que
nous racontent comment on peut penser
deux fois qualité pour moi on peut
passer quelque chose de négatif à
positif
peut être que je vais aborder les lycées
réponse à votre question
avec la prochaine question c'est de
savoir en fait
et si vos défauts étaient des qualités
et pour cela je vous propose de parler
mois de mai difficile
je vais vous parler de mes défauts et de
comment je me suis appuyé sur cd sont là
pour développer les qualités qu'on dise
on y meurt un prix bien mais je voudrais
qu'on cheminent ensemble je vais voir
passer un peu mon cas personnel un peu
mon histoire oci
quand j'avais l'âge de 58 ans
je vous rassure je suis ni les lieux
donc on paye surtout le travail des
mawaï été pour les études donc je suis
en vacances vous j'ai commencé mon école
qui n'est à la hauteur la montage avant
d'aller vous et que tout le monde parle
français
même sans aller à l'école et moi j'ai eu
un deuxième passage qui était d'aller à
l'école donc sa vélocité d'un peu
sexualité français est tout petit peu je
n'avais jamais fait que sinon je me
rappelle pas un c'est les gens qui
meurent avant tout
en fait je colliger toutes les fautes
que les gens se ferme à présent ce soir
le vocabulaire l'abdomen je me soucie
être ainsi au dj plus âgées que moi si
vous aviez un statut plus élevé que
venir fait une faute novembre je vous
connais un peu large eu lieu aussi au
collège juillet au jeu colliger les
enseignants pas diffuser les erreurs
a fait selon un décompte qui tu avais
fait les théories ça nous permettait la
vie absolument l université j'évolue
dans plusieurs commissions des affaires
culturelles comme monsieur satie et et
les commissions où la plupart des
étudiants
on veut ou virement 7,15 de se soulever
contre les responsables de prendre te le
dire ce qui se perçoit 10 les moins
quand je ne suis pas d'un poil avec
quelque chose quand je trouve que cette
chose n'est pas juste je n'hésite pas à
le faire savoir
aujourd'hui je suis active autour de la
santé de la population et le planning
familial
je vous apprends rien c'est une
thématique qui est pas vous thématiques
qui est très sensible dans notre pays
mais je n'ai pas honte de la beauté je
n'ai pas peur de la beauté parce que je
sais qu'il ya des progrès qu'il faut
trouver des solutions à ces problèmes et
ce n'est pas en restant dans le silence
qu'on peut trouver des solutions il faut
qu'on chantera vous l'aurez compris
monde est frais quand je suis en train
de parler prend des photos juil quand je
parle les et que en fait je suis
quelqu'un qui n'a pas froid aux yeux
c'est un défaut dans la société à ce que
les personnes qui n'ont pas froid aux
yeux sont des façons qui manque de
respect parce que oui je peux m'estimer
oui j'ai du respect pour personne
ce sont des personnes qui n'ont pas de
la considération pour les autres qui se
croient supérieurs aux autres parce
qu'il s'explique sur des personnes qui
sont subjectives
parce que oui je peux m'exprimer seul
mon avis compte seuls mes émotions comme
celle des sentiments quand je ne suis
pas ce genre de personne qui n'a pas
froid aux yeux
je suis ce genre de personne qui n'a
parfois aux yeux mais qui est
respectueuse je suis une personne qui
n'a pas froid aux yeux
mais qui a de la considération pour les
autres ce genre de faire sans qui n'a
pas froid aux yeux et qui est objectif
parce que je veux porter mes idées je
veux défendre mes idées de bon qui que
ce soit je veux que cela soit juste
moi et pour les autres je peux vous dire
que si dans la salle quelqu'un n'a pas
froid aux yeux
je vous dis que c'est une qualité c'est
peu vu naître parce que c'est quelque
chose qui peut vous permettre de saisir
les opportunités de vous tuer même les
opportunités là où il n'y en a pas de
faire du plaidoyer et de révision
changer les choses
départ laissez-vous de la timidité
débarrassez-vous de la honte
débarrassez-vous de la crainte de la
pomme et ayez confiance en mon deuxième
défaut que j'aimerais aborder avec vous
en parle on va aussi cheminé en train de
faire c'est fou non
quand j'étais en classe de cm2 après le
premier trimestre de composition
enseignants a dit yves et les bleus
étaient en classe et avait une de mes
camarades qui avaient 8 de moyenne
moi j'avais eu six de moins que celui à
l'origine sa demande et applaudir moins
de la fixité à si elle allait passer de
6 de moins à 8 de moins on a un petit
poulet dans la vie l'idée est là je me
suis dit mais moi aussi j'ai envie qu'on
applaudit mais moi aussi j'ai envie
qu'on me félicite est tout petit que
j'étais je suis rentré à la maison
je savais que j'avais des lacunes j'ai
établi un programme de révision et j'ai
fait en sorte de deuxième trimestre 2008
je suis arrivé au collège il y avait le
maintien j'étais particulièrement bonne
c'était l'anglais
j'avais tout le temps 19 20 et il y
avait une de mes camarades qui commence
est dangereusement se rapprocher de moi
alors bretez avoir des quinze des seize
je suis dit mes attentes elle fait ce
qu'elle veut pas ma place moi je voulais
car vu le plâtre donc j'ai redoublé
encore plus d'efforts et si elle avait
18 j'avais 19 ans il avait dit m j'avais
20 était consacrée conserver ma place
j'ai fait ses concurrents cela un atout
pour pouvoir redoubler d'efforts donner
le meilleur de moi-même un premier rejet
en classe quand je suis allé en classe
de troisième
j'étais assez bon élève j'étais
cinquième de ma classe mais je voulais
tourner la première de notre place je me
suis dit mais ratant est là et les
premières lumières de remercier les
premières que moi sur le premier il faut
que je me donne les moyens d'être
première mais là j'ai joué double vie de
faire manger des jouets je n'ai pas
réussi à la détruit mais parce que
j'avais fait défaut et j'avais travaillé
je suis pressé de 5e en mal de ma classe
troisième de magna une identité et donc
tout ce que je fais avec les jeunes
ambassadeurs pour la santé la production
je veux tout en est la meilleure je veux
tout ce temps me démarquer je veux tout
en choisissent que oui c'est moi la
mieux et je veux aussi veut dire
inquiétant
le coaching était de la meilleure de
celle qui amène les gens avec qui je
veux tous entre eux disent que oui c'est
ma ville je me rappelle qu' il ya eu la
conférence internationale sur le plat
est familière à novembre 2018
et tenez vous bien c'est les fans
nouveau aucun jeune du niger niamey
jamais fatigué je suis dit mais pourquoi
et j'ai eu en main dit il faut faire une
vidéo et il faut faire de la vidéo un
angle gic et c'est ça qu'on veut pas
faire j'ai fait ma vidéo la vidéo en
anglais j'ai été retenu pour activer à
la conférence internationale sur le
planning familial mais je me suis pas
allé là bas il y avait une compétition
qu'on appelait la confession de
plaidoyer en challenge au moci
d'habitude le niger n'y avait pas déjà
l'impact
je me suis dis qu'il faut que les jeunes
pratiquent mais surtout il faut que le
niger gagne je suis parti avec un projet
le plaidoyer gbit ils m'ont posé le
plaidoyer ne vont plus de 4000 personnes
les gens ont voté et le niger a inventé
le premier vide livré
[Musique]
on vous dira que ce défaut que j'ai
c'est que je suis envieuses
j'ai eu envie et je ne suis pas mais
tenez vous bien attention je suis pas ce
genre de cas sont envieuses qui est
jalouse de la limite des eaux de vue un
tel ali avec les manches non je ne suis
pas ce genre de cas sont un lieu qui
freine la regideso de lui un talent
[Applaudissements]